let's imagine three servers with logs
that looked like this where the numbers
I'm writing are the term numbers of the
command that's in that log entry so we
don't really care what the actual
commands are then I got a number the log
slots and so let's imagine that the
presumably the the next term is term six
although you can't actually tell that
from looking the evidence on the board
but it must be at least six or greater
let's imagine that server s3 is chosen
as the leader for term six and at some
point s3 the new leader is going to want
to send out a new log entry so let's
suppose it wants to send out its first
log entry per term six so we're sort of
thinking about the append entries our
PCs that the leader is going to send out
to carry the first log entry for term
six really should be under slot thirteen
the rules in Figure two say that an
append entries are bc actually as - as
well as the command that the client sent
in to the leader that we want to
replicate on the logs of all the
followers there's this append entries
RPC also contains this previous log
index field and a previous log term
field and when we're sending out an end
pend entries for where this is the first
entry we're leaders supposed to put
information about the previous slot the
slot before the new information sending
out so in this case the log index of the
previous entry is 12 and the term of the
command in the leaders log for the
previous entry is by so sends out this
information to the followers
and the followers before they accept a
upend entries are supposed to check you
know they know they've received an
append entries that for some log entries
that start here and the first thing they
do is check that there are previous the
receiving followers check that their
previous log entry matches the previous
information that follow that the leader
sent out so for a server to of course it
doesn't match the server to has a entry
here all right but it's an entry from
term for not from turn five and so the
server twos going to reject this append
entries and sort of send a false reply
back leader and server one doesn't even
have anything here so server ones gonna
also reject the append entries in the
leader and so so far so good right the
terrible thing that that has been
averted at this point is you know the
bad thing we absolutely don't want to
see is that server to actually stuck the
new blog entry in here which would break
sort of inductive proofs essentially
that the figure to scheme relies on and
hide the fact that server two actually
had a different log so instead of
accepting log entry server two projects
this RPC the leader sees is two
rejections and leader is maintaining
this next index field one for each
follower so it has a next index for
server two and the leader has a next
index for server one presumably if the
should have said this before if the
server sending out information about
slot thirteen here that must mean that
the server's next index is for both of
these other servers this started out as
thirteen and that would be the case at
the server if this leader had just
restarted because the figure two rules
say that next index starts out at the
end of the new leaders log and so in
response to errors the leaders supposed
to decrement its next in
steal so it does that for both got
errors from boat deca mr. Calvin resends
and this time the server is going to
send out append entries with previous
log index equals 11
and previous log term equals 3 and this
new append entries has it has a
different previous log index but it's
the content in the log entries that the
server is going to send out this time
include you know all the entries after
that the new previous log index is
sending out so server 2 now the previous
log index 11 it looks there and it sees
a ha you know the term is 3 same as what
the reader is sending me so server 2 is
actually going to accept this append
entries and figure 2 rules say oh if you
accept a pendent we supposed to delete
everything in your log after where the
append entry starts and replace it with
whatever's in the append entries so
server tune is going to do that now it's
he just went to 5 6 server 1 still has a
problem cuz it has nothing at slot 11
middle would return another error the
server will now backup its server 1 next
index 2 11 it'll send out its log
starting here with the previous index
and term referring now to this slot and
this one's actually acceptable server 1
it'll adopt it'll accept the new log
entries and send a positive response
back to the server and now they're all
now they're all caught up and the
presumably the server also when it sees
that followers accepted and append
entries that had a certain number of log
entries it actually increments this next
index could be 14 4 alright so the net
effect of all this backing up is that
the server has used a backup mechanism
to detect the point at which the
followers logs
started to be equal to this
servers and then sent each of the
followers starting from that point that
a complete remainder of the server's log
after that last point at which they were
equal any questions all right
just to repeat discussion we've had
before and we'll probably have again you
notice that we erased some blog entries
here which are now su erase that I
forget what they were 4 & 5 so there
were some well actually that was mostly
remember we erased this log entry here
this used to say for um server - the
question is why was it ok for the system
to forget about this client command
right this thing we erased corresponds
to some client command which are now
throwing away I talked about this
yesterday what's the rationale here yeah
so it's not a majority of the servers
and therefore whatever previous leader
it was who sent this out couldn't have
gotten acknowledgments from a majority
of servers therefore that previous
leader couldn't have decided it was
committed couldn't have executed it and
applied it to the application state
could never have sent a positive reply
back to the client so because this isn't
done a majority of servers we know that
the client who send in and has no reason
to believe it was executed couldn't have
gotten a reply because one of the rules
is the server only sends over the leader
only sends a reply to a client after it
commits and executes so the client had
no reason to believe it was even
received by any server and then and the
rules of figure to basically say the
client if he gets no response after a
while it supposed to resend the request
so we know whatever request this was it
threw away we've never executed never
included in any state already and the
clients gonna resend it by-and-by yes
well it's always deleting suffix of the
followers log I mean in the end the sort
of backup answer to this is that the
leader has a complete log so all its
fails it can just send us complete log
to the follower and indeed if you know
if you've just started up the system and
something very strange happened even at
the very beginning then you may end up
actually you know maybe in some of the
tests for lab two you may end up backing
up to the very first entry and then
having the leader essentially send the
whole log but because the leader has
this whole law we know it could sort of
it's got all the information that's
required to feel everybody's logs if it
needs to
okay all right so in this example which
I guess are now erased we elected s3 as
the leader and the question is could we
you know who can we who are we allowed
to elect this leader right cool
you know that all right if you read the
paper you know the answer is not just
anyone it turns out it matters a lot for
the correctness the correctness of the
system that we don't allow just anyone
to be the leader like for example the
first node whose timer goes off may in
fact not be an acceptable leader and so
it turns out raft has some rules that
applies about oh yes you can be leader
or you can't be leader and to see why
this is true let's sort of set up a
straw man proposal that maybe raft
should accept should use the server with
the longest log as the leader right you
know some alternate universe that could
be true and it is actually true in
systems with different designs just not
in raft so the question we're
investigating is why not use the
cervical longest law as leader and this
would involve changing the voting rules
in raft have a voters only vote for
nodes that have longer logs all right so
the example that's going to be
convenient for showing why this is a bad
idea so let's imagine we have three
servers again and now the log set setups
are server Wan has entries for terms
five six and seven server two four five
and eight and server three also four
five and eight that's the first question
of course to avoid spending our time
scratching our heads about utter
nonsense is to make sure that convince
ourselves that this configuration could
actually arise because if it couldn't
possibly arise then
may be a waste of time to figure out
what would happen if it did arise so
anybody wanna propose a sequence of
events whereby this set of logs could
have arisen how about an argument that
it couldn't have arisen oh yeah okay so
well maybe we'll back up sometime
all right so server one wins is wins the
election at this point and it's in term
six sends out yeah it receives a client
request sends out the first append
entries and then that's fine actually
everything's fine so far nothing's wrong
all right well a good bet for all these
things is then it crashes right or it
receives the client requests in term six
it appends the client requests to its
own log which it does first and it's
about to send out a pen entries but it
crashes yes it didn't send out any pen
entries and then you know we need then
it crashes and restarts very quickly
there's a new election and gosh server
one is elected again as the as the new
leader it receives in term seven and
receives a client request appends it to
its log and then it crashes right and
then after after a crashes we have a new
election maybe server 2 gets elected
this time maybe server 1 is down now so
off the table if server 2 is elected at
this point suppose server 1 is still
dead what term is server what server two
venues
yeah eights the right answer so why
eight and not remember this you know
this is now gone why eight and not six
that's absolutely right so not written
on the board but in order for server one
to have been elected here it must have
votes from majority of nodes which
include at least one of server-to-server
three if you look at the vote request
code and figure two if you vote for
somebody you're you're supposed to
record the term in persistent storage
and that means that either server 2 or
server 3 are both new about term six and
in fact term seven and therefore when
sever one dies and they cannot elect a
new leader at least one of them knows
that the current term was eight if that
one and only that one actually if
there's only one of them only that one
could win an election because it has the
higher terminal birth they both know
about term eight sorry if they both know
about term seven then they'll both and
either one of them will try to be leader
and term eight so that fact of that the
next term must be term a dis is insured
by the property of the majorities must
overlap and the fact that current term
is updated by vote request and is
persistent and guarantee did not be lost
even if there were some crashes here so
the next term is going to be eight
server two or server three will win the
leadership election and let's just
imagine that whichever one it is sends
out append entries for a new client
requests the other one gets it and so
now we have this configuration right so
I was a bit of a detour we're back to
our original question of in this
configuration suppose server one revives
we have an election would it be okay to
use server one would it be okay to have
the rule be the longest log wins the
longest log gets to be the leader yeah
obviously not right because server was a
leader did it's going to force its log
on to the to followers by the append
entries machinery that we just talked
about a few minutes ago
if we live server one to be the leader
it's gonna you know sent out a pen
entries whatever backup overwrite these
aids tell the followers to erase their
log entries for term a to accept to
overwrite them with this six and seven
log entries and then to proceed now with
identical to server ones so of course
why are we upset about this yeah yeah
exactly it was already committed right
it's not a majority of servers has
already committed probably executed
quite possibly a reply sent to a client
so we're not entitled to delete it and
therefore server one cannot be allowed
to become leader and force its log onto
servers two and three everybody see why
that's bad idea for rapid and because of
that this can't possibly have been rule
for elections of course shortest log
didn't work too well either and so in
fact if you read forward to section
something five point four point one
draft actually has a slightly more
sophisticated election restriction that
the request vote handling RPC handling
code is supposed to check before it says
yes before votes yes for a different
peer and the rule is we only vote you
vote yes for some candidate who send us
over request votes only if candidate has
a higher
term in the last log entry or same last
term same charming the last log entry
and a log length that's greater than or
equal to the the server that received
that received the boat request and so if
we apply this here if server two gets a
vote request from server one there our
last log entry terms or seven the server
one's gonna send out a request votes
with a last entry term whatever of 7
server twos is eight so this isn't true
server service we didn't get a request
from somebody with a higher term in the
last entry and or the last entry terms
aren't the same either said the second
Clause doesn't apply either so neither
server to new serve nor server three is
going to vote for server one and so even
if it sends out this vote requests first
because this has a shorter election
timeout nobody's going to vote for it
except itself so I don't think it's one
vote it's not a majority if either
server two or server three becomes a
candidate then either of them will
accept the other because they have the
same last term number and their logs are
each greater than or equal to in length
and the others so either of them will
vote for for the other one will server
one vote for either of them
yes because either server 2 or server 3
has a higher term number in the last
entry so you know what this is doing is
making sure that you can only become a
candidate if or it prefers candidates
that knew about higher that have log
entries some higher terms that is it
prefers candidates that are more likely
to have been receiving log entries from
the previous leader and you know this
second part says well we were all
listening to the previous leader then
we're going to
for the server that has saw more
requests from the very last leader any
questions about the election restriction
okay final thing about sending out log
entries is that this rollback scheme at
least as I described it and it's as its
described in Figure two rolls back one
log entry at a time and you know
probably a lot of fun that's okay
but there are situations maybe in the
real world and definitely in the lab
tests where backing up one entry at a
time is going to take a long long time
and so the real-world situation where
that might be true is if they if a
follower has been down for a long time
and missed a lot of upend entries and
the leader restarts and if you follow
the pseudocode in Figure two if a leader
restarts is supposed to set its next
index to the end of the leaders log so
if the follower has been down and you
know miss the last thousand log entries
and leader reboots the leader is gonna
have to walk back off one at a time one
RPC at a time all thousand of those log
entries that the follower missed and
there's no you know particular reason
why this would never happen in real life
it could easily happen at somewhat more
contrived situation that the tests are
definitely explorers is if a follower is
if we say we have five servers and
there's there's a leader but the leaders
got trapped with one follower in a
network partition but the leader doesn't
know it's not leader anymore and it's
still sending out append entries to its
one follower and none of which are
committed while in the other majority
partition the system is continuing as
usual the ex leader and follower in that
Minority partition could end up putting
in their logs you know sort of unlimited
numbers of log entries for a stale term
that will never be committed and need to
be deleted and overwritten eventually
when they rejoin the main group that's
maybe a little less likely in the real
world but you'll see it happen and the
test set up so in order to be able to
back up faster that paper has
somewhat a vague description of a faster
scheme towards the end of section 5.3
it's a little bit hard to interpret so
I'm gonna try to explain what their
ideas about how to back up faster a
little bit better and the general idea
is to be able to to have the follower
send enough information to the leader
that the leader can jump back an entire
terms worth of entries that have to be
deleted per append entries so it leader
may only have to send one in a pennant
and append entries per term in which the
leader and follower disagree instead of
one per entry so there's three cases I
think are important and the fact is that
you can probably think of many different
log backup acceleration strategies and
here's one so I'm going to divide the
kinds of situations you might see into
three cases so this is fast backup case
one I'm just going to talk about one
follower and the leader and not worry
about the other nodes the same we have
two server one which is the follower and
server 2 which is the leader so this is
one case and here we need to backup over
a term where that term is entirely
missing from the leader another case
so in this case we need to back up over
some entries but their entries for a
term that the leader actually knows
about so apparently the this followers
saw a couple of entry a couple of the
very Flass few append entries sent out
by a leader that was about to crash but
the new leader didn't see them we still
need to back up over them and a third
case is where the followers entirely
missing the following the leader agree
but the followers is missing the end of
the leaders log and I believe you can
take care of all three of these with
three pieces of extra information in the
reply that a follower sends back to the
leader in the case in the append entries
so we're talking about the append
entries reply if the follower rejects
the append entries because the logs
don't agree there's three pieces of
information that will be useful and
taking care of three street cases I'll
call them X term which is the term of
the conflicting entry I remember the
leader sent this previous log term and
if the follower rejects it because it
has something here but the terms wrong
so it'll put the followers term for the
conflicting entry here or you know I'm
negative one or something it doesn't
have anything in the log there it'll
also send back the index of the
conflicting but the index are the first
entry with that term
and finally if there wasn't any log
entry there at all the follower will
send back on the length of its law like
the followers log so for case one the
way this helps if the it's a leader sees
that the leader doesn't even have an
entry with X term of term X term at all
in its log so that's this case where the
leader didn't have turn five and if the
leader can simply back up to the
beginning of the followers run of
entries with X term that is the the
leader can set its next index to this X
index thing which is the first entry the
followers run of items from term five
alright so if the leader doesn't have X
term at all it should back up to X back
the follower up to X index the second
case you can detect the fault the leader
can detect if X term is valid and the
leader actually has log entries of term
X term that's the case here where the
you know the disagreement is here but
the leader actually has some entries
that term in that case the leader should
back up to the last entry it has that
has the contesta followers term for the
conflicting term in it that is the last
entry that a leader has for term for in
this case and if neither of these two
cases hold that is the well actually if
the follower indicates by maybe setting
X term to minus one it actually didn't
have anything whatsoever at the
conflicting log and index because it's
log is too short then the leader should
back up its next index to the last entry
that the follower had at all and start
sending from there
and I'm telling you this because it'll
be useful for doing a lab and if you
miss some of my description it's it's in
electronics then any questions about
this backing up business Jack I think
that's true yeah yeah yeah maybe binary
search I'm not ruling out other
solutions I mean that you know after
reading the papers non description of
how to do it I like cook this up and
there's probably other ways to do this
probably better ways and faster ways of
doing it like I'm I'm sure that if
you're willing to send back more
information or have a more sophisticated
strategy like binary search you can do a
better job yeah well you you almost
certainly need to do something
experience suggests that in order to
pass the tests you'll need to do
something to as well probably not me
although I that's not quite true like
one of the solutions I've written over
the years actually does the stupid thing
and still passes the tests but because
the tests you know the one of the sort
of unfortunate but inevitable things
about the tests we give you is that they
have a bit of a real time requirement
that is the tests are not willing to
wait forever for your solution to
produce an answer so it is possible to
have a solution that's you know
technically correct but takes so long
that the tester gives up and
unfortunately you know we will the
tester will fail you if your solution
doesn't finish the test and whatever the
time limit is and therefore you do
actually have to pay some attention to
performance in order you know your
solution has to be both correct and have
enough performance to finish before the
tester gets bored and sometimes out on
you which is like 10 minutes or I don't
know what it is and unfortunately it's
relatively this stuff's complex enough
that it's not that hard to write a color
correction
that's not fast enough yes so the way
you can tap the leader can tell the
difference is that the follower we're
supposed to send back the term number it
sees in the conflicting entry you we
have case one if the leader does not
have that term in its log
so here the follower will set X term to
five to five because this is this is
going to be the this is gonna be the
conflicting entry the follower says this
X term to five the leader observes oh I
do not have term five in my log and
therefore this case one and you know it
should back up to the beginning
like it doesn't follower hasn't leader
has none of those and term five entry so
it should just get rid of all of them in
the follower by backing up to the
beginning which is X index yeah yeah
because the leaders gonna back up its
next index to here and then send an
append entries that starts here and the
rules a figure to say ah the follower
just has to replace its log so it is
gonna get rid of the fives okay alright
the next thing I want to talk about is
persistence you'll notice in Figure two
that the state in the upper left-hand
corners sort of divided and summer
marked persistent and some are marked
volatile and what's going on here is
that the the distinction between
persistence and volatile you know only
matters if a server reboots crashes and
restarts because the persistent what the
persistent means is that if you change
one of those items it's marked
persistent you're supposed to the server
supposed to write it to disk or to some
other non-volatile storage like as
or battery-backed something or whatever
that will ensure that if the server
restarts that it will be able to find
that information and sort of reload it
into memory and that's to allow us to
allow servers to be able to pick up
where they left off if they crash and
restart now you might think that it
would it would be sufficient and simpler
to say well if a server crashes then we
just throw it away and or we need to be
able to throw it away and replace it
with a brand-new empty server and bring
it up to speed right and of course you
do actually it is vital to be able to do
that right because if some server
suffers a failure of some catastrophic
failure like it's you know disk melts or
something you absolutely need to be able
to replace it and you cannot count on
getting anything useful off its disk if
something bad happened to its disk so we
absolutely need to be able to replace
completely replace servers that have no
state whatsoever you might think that's
sufficient to handle any difficulties
but it's actually not it turns out that
another common failure mode is power
failure of you know the entire cluster
where they all stop executing at the
same time right and in that case we
can't handle or we can't handle that
failure by simply throwing away the
servers and replacing them with new
hardware that we buy from Dell we
actually have to be able to get off the
ground we need to be able to get a copy
of the state back in order to keep
executing if we want our service to be
fault tolerant and therefore in order at
least in order to handle the situation
of simultaneous power failure we have to
have a way for the server's to sort of
save their state somewhere where it will
be available when the power returns and
that's one way of viewing what's going
on with persistence it said that's the
state that's required
to get a server going again I'm after
either a single power failure or power
failure of the entire cluster
alright so figure two this three items
only three items are persistent so
there's a log that's like all the log
entries current term and voted for and
by the way you know one of us server
reboots it actually has to make an
explicit check to make sure that these
data are valid on its disk before it
rejoins the raft cluster I have to have
some way of saying oh yeah I actually do
have some save persistent state as
opposed to a bunch of zeros that that
are not valid all right so the reason
why log has to be persisted is that at
least according to figure two this is
the only record of the application state
that is figure two doesn't really have a
notion fears two does not say that we
have to persist the application state so
if we're running a database or you know
a test and set service like for vmware
ft the actual database or the actual
value of the test and set flag isn't
persistent according to figure two only
the logins and so when the server
restarts the only information available
to reconstruct the application state is
the sequence of commands in the log and
so that has to be persisted that's what
about current term why does current term
have to be persistent
yeah so they're both about ensuring that
there's only one that each term has at
most one leader so yeah so voted for the
specific you know potential damaging
case is that if a server receives a boat
request and votes for server one and
then it crashes and if it didn't persist
this the identity of who had voted for
and in my crash we start get another
boat request for the same term from
server two and say gosh I haven't voted
for anybody because my voted for is
blank
now I'm gonna vote for server 2 and now
our servers voted for server 1 and for
server 2 in the same term and that might
allow two servers
since both server and server to voted
for themselves they both may think they
have a majority out of three and they're
both going to become leader now we have
two simultaneous servers for the same
term so this that's why I voted for it
has to be persistent current term is
gonna be a little more subtle but we
actually talked before about how you
know again we don't want to have more
than one server for a term and if we
don't know what term number it is then
we can't necessarily then it may be hard
to ensure that there's only one server
for a term and I think maybe in this
example ya if s if server 1 was down and
server 2 and server 3 we're gonna try to
elect a new server they need evidence
that the correct turn numbers 8 and not
6 right because if they if they forgot
about current term and it was just
server 2 and server 3 voting for each
other and they only had their log to
look at they might think the next term
should be term 6 they did that they
start producing stuff for term 6 but now
there's gonna be a lot of confusion
because we have two different term sixes
and so that's the reason my current term
has to be persistent to preserve
evidence about term numbers that have
already been used these have to be
persisted pretty much every time you
change them right so certainly the safe
thing to do is every time you add an
entry of log or change current term
are said voted for you need you probably
need to persist that and in a real raft
server that would mean writing it to the
disk so you'd have some set of files
that recorded this stuff you can
probably be a little bit you may be can
cut some corners if you observed that
you don't need to persist these things
until you communicate with the outside
world so there may be some opportunity
for a little bit of batching by saying
well we don't have to persist anything
until we're about to reply to an RPC or
about to send out an RPC I mean that may
allow you to avoid a few persisting x'
the reason that's important is that
writing stuff to disk is can be very
expensive it's a if it's a mechanical
hard drive that we're talking about then
writing anything you know if the way
we're persisting is writing files on the
disk writing anything on the disk cost
you about 10 milliseconds because you
either have to wait for the disk to spin
for the point you want to write to spin
under the head which disk only rotates
about once every 10 milliseconds or
worse that you may actually have to seek
to move the arm the right track right so
these per systems can be terribly
terribly expensive and if for sort of
any kind of straightforward design
they're likely to be the limiting factor
in performance because they mean that
doing anything anything whatsoever on
these graph servers takes ten
milliseconds a pop and 10 milliseconds
as far longer than it takes to say send
an RPC or almost anything else you might
do 10 milliseconds each means you can
just never if you persist data to a
mechanical drive you just can never
build a raft service it can serve more
than 100 requests per second because
that's what you get it at 10
milliseconds per operation and you know
this is this cost so this is really all
about cost of synchronous
just updates and it comes up in many
systems like file systems the file
systems that are running in your laptops
are that the designers spend a huge
amount of time sort of trying to
navigate around the performance problems
of synchronous disk up they think of as
disk writes because in order for stuff
to get safe on your disk in order to
update the file system on your laptop's
disk safely there turns out the file
system has to like be careful about how
it writes and needs to sometimes wait
for the disk to finish writing so this
is a like a cross-cutting issue in all
kinds of systems certainly comes up in
draft if you want it to build a system
they could serve more than a hundred
quests per second then there's a bunch
of options one is you can use a
solid-state drive or some kind of flash
or something solid eight drives can do a
write to the flash memory in maybe a
tenth of a millisecond so that's a
factor of a hundred for you or if you're
even more sophisticated maybe you can
build yourself battery backed DRAM and
do the persistence into battery back
DRAM and then if the server reboots hope
that reboot was took shorter than the
amount of time the battery lasts and
that this stuff you persisted is still
in the RAM and the reason I mean if you
have money and sophistication the reason
to favor that is you can write DRAM you
know millions of times per second and so
it's probably not going to be a
performance bottleneck anyway so that
this problem is why and it's sort of
marking a persistent versus volatile and
figure 2 is like has a lot of
significance for performance as well as
crash recovery and correctness any
questions about persisting yeah
yes alright so your question is
basically you're writing code say go
code for your raft implementation or
you're trying to write a real rafterman
implementation and you actually want to
make sure that when you persist your an
update to the law or the current term or
whatever that it in fact will be there
after a crash and reboot like what's the
recipe for what you have to do to make
sure it's there and your observation
that if you call you know on a UNIX or
Linux or whatever Mac if you call right
you know the right system call is how
you write to a disk file you simply call
right as you pointed out it is not the
case that after the write returns the
data is safe on disk and will survive a
reboot it almost certainly isn't almost
certainly not on disk so the you know
the particular piece of magic you need
to do is on unix at any rate you need
you need to call right so you cannot
write some file you've opened that's
going to contain the stuff that you want
to write and then you got a call this F
st. call which on most systems the
guarantee is that F sync doesn't return
until all the data you've previously
written into this file is safely on the
surface on the media in a place on a
place where it will still be there if
there's a crash so so this thing is some
then this call is an expensive call and
that's why it's a separate that's why
Wright doesn't write the disk only F
sync does is because it's so expensive
you would never want to do it unless you
really wanted to persist some stuff some
data okay so you can use more expensive
disk hardware the other trick people
play a lot is to try to batch that is if
you can if client requests are if you
have a lot of client requests coming in
maybe you should accept a lot of them
and not reply to any of them for a
little bit we call a lot of them
accumulate
and then persist you know a hundred log
entries at a time from your hundred
clients and you know only then send out
the append entries good because you do
actually have to persist this stuff to
disk if you receive a client request you
have to persist the new entry to disk
before you send the append entries our
PCs the followers because you're not
allowed if the leader you know the
leader it's essentially promising to
commit that that request and can't
forget about it
and indeed the followers have to persist
the new log entry to their disk before
they reply to the append entries because
they were apply to the append entries
it's also a promise to preserve and
eventually commit that log entry so they
can't be allowed to forget about it if
they crash other questions about
persistence all right well final you
know a little detail about persistence
is that some of the stuff in figure two
is not persistent and so it's worth
scratching your head a little bit about
why commit index lasts apply next index
and match index why it's fair game for
them to be simply thrown away if the
server crashes and restarts like why
wasn't you know commit index or last
apply it like geez last applied is the
record of how much we've executed right
if we throw that away aren't we gonna
execute log entries twice and is that
correct how about that why is why is it
safe to throw away last applied
yes I am we're all about simplicity and
safety here with raft so that's exactly
correct the the reason why all that
other stuff can be non-volatile as you
mentioned I mean sorry volatile the
reason why those other fields can be
volatile and thrown away is that we can
the leader can reconstruct sort of
what's been committed by inspecting its
own log and by the results of append
entries that it sends out to the
followers I mean initially the leader if
it if everybody restarts because they
experienced a power failure
initially the leader does not know
what's committed what's executed but
when it sends out log and append entries
it'll sort of gather back information
and essentially from the followers about
What's in how much of their logs match
the leaders and therefore how much must
have been committed before the crash
another thing in the 4-2 world which is
not the real world
another thing about figure two is that
figure two assumes that the application
state is destroyed and thrown away if
there's a crash in a restart so the
figure two world assumes that while log
is persistent that the application state
is absolutely not persistent required
not to be consistent in figure 2 because
the in figure 2 the log is preserved
persisted from the very beginning of the
system and so what's going to happen if
you sort of play out what the various
rules in figure 2 after a leader restart
is that the leader will eventually re
execute every single log entry that is
handed to the application you know
starting with log entry one after a
reboot it's the raft is gonna hand the
application every log entry starting
from one and so that will after a
restart the application will completely
reconstruct its state from scratch by a
replay from the beginning of the time of
the entire log after each restart and
again that's like a sort of
straightforward elegant plan but
obviously potentially very slow
which brings us to the next topic which
is log compaction and and snapshots and
this has a lot to do with lab 3b
actually you'll see log compaction and
snapshots in vlog 3b in lab 3b and so
the problem that log compaction and
snapshotting is solving a raft is that
indeed for a long-running system that's
been going for weeks or months or years
if we just follow the figure 2 rules the
log just keeps on growing may end up you
know millions and millions of entries
long and so requires a lot of memory to
store if you store it on disk like if
you have to persist it every time you
persist the log it's using up a huge I
may not space on disk and if a server
ever be starts it has to reconstruct its
state by replaying these millions and
millions of log entries from the very
beginning which could take like hours
for a server to run through its entire
log and we execute it if it crashes and
restarts all of which is like similar
what kind of wasted because before it
crashed it had already had applications
state and so in order to cope with this
wrath has this idea of snapshots and the
sort of idea behind snapshots is to be
able to save or ask the application to
save a copy of its state as of a
particular log entry so we've been
mostly kind of ignoring the application
but the fact is that you know if we have
a suppose we're building a key value
store under BRAF you know the log is
gonna contain a bunch of you know
putting gets or read and write request
so maybe a law contains you know a put
that some client wants to set X to one
and then another one where it says X to
2 and then you know y equals 7 or
whatever and if there's no crashes as
the raft is executing along there's
going to be this if the layer above Rath
there's going to be this application and
the application if it's a key value
store databases it's going to be meeting
this table and as raft hands it one
command after our next
the applications going to update its
table so you know after the first
command it's going to set X to one and
it's stable after the second command
it's going to update its table you know
one interesting fact is that for most
applications the application state is
likely to be much smaller than the
corresponding log right at some level we
know that the the you know the log and
the state are the log in that and the
state as of some point in the log are
kind of interchangeable right they both
sort of implied the same thing about the
state of the application but the log may
contain a lot of you know a lot of
multiple assignments 2x they use up a
lot of space in the log but are also to
effectively compact it down to a single
entry in the table and that's pretty
typical of these replicated applications
but the point is that instead of storing
the log which may go to be huge we have
the option of storing instead the table
which might be a lot smaller and that's
what the snapshots are doing so when
raft feels that it's log has gotten to
be too large you know more than a
megabyte or ten megabytes or whatever
some arbitrary limit raft will ask the
application to take make a snapshot of
it the application state as of a certain
point in the log
so if we add if raft asked the
application for a snapshot reference it
would pick a point in the log that the
snapshot referred to and require the
application to produce a snapshot as at
that point this is extremely critical
because the because what we're about to
do is throw away everything before that
point so if there's not a will to find
point that corresponds to a snapshot
then we can't safely throw away the log
before that point so that means that
Rath is gonna have you know ask for
snaps on the snap so it's basically just
the table it's just about a database
server and we also need to annotate the
snapshot with the entry number that are
corresponds to you so it's basically you
know if the entries are 1 2 3 this
snapshot corresponds to just after log
index 3 with the snapshot in hand
if we persist it to disk rats persistent
to disk raft never again will need this
part of the logs and it can simply throw
it away as long as it persists a
snapshot as of a certain in debt log
index plus the log after that index as
long as that's persisted to disk we
never going to need to log before that
and so this is what RAF does the rocks
ask the application for snapshot gets
the snapshot saves it to disk with the
log after that it just throws away this
log here right and so it really operates
or the sort of persistence story is all
about pairs of a snapshot in the log
after that after the point in the log
associated with snapshot I don't see
this yes
no it's still it's it's you know there's
these sort of phantom entries one two
three and this you know suffix of the
log is indeed viewed as still the it's
maybe the right way to think of it is
still there's just one log except these
entries are sort of phantom entries that
we that we can view as being kind of
there in principle but since we're we
never need to look at them because we
have the snapshot the fact that they
just happened not to be stored anywhere
is neither here nor there but it's but
yeah you should think of it as being
stole the same log it's just not just
threw away their early entries did this
that's a maybe a little bit too glib of
an answer because the fact is that
figure two talks about the log in ways
that makes it that if you just follow
figure to you sometimes still need these
earlier entries and so you'll have to
reinterpret figure two a little bit in
light of the fact that sometimes it says
blah blah blah a log entry where the log
entry doesn't exist okay
okay and so what happens on a restart
so the restart story is a little more
complicated in it than it used to be
with just a log what happens on a
restart is that there needs to be away
for raft to give the latest for graph to
find the latest snapshot log pair on its
disk and hand the snapshot to the
application because we no longer are
able to replay you know all the log
entries so there must be some other way
to initialize the application basically
not only is the application have to be
able to produce a snapshot of
application state but but it has to be
able to absorb a previously made
snapshot and sort of reconstruct it
stable in memory from a snapshot and so
this now even though raft is kind of
managing this whole snapshotting stuff
the snapshot contents are really the
property to the application and RAF
doesn't even understand what's in here
only the application does because it's
all full of application specific
information so after a restart the
application has to be able to absorb the
latest snapshot that raft found so for
just this simple it would be simple
unfortunately this snapshotting and in
particular the idea that the leader
might throw away part of its log
introduces a major piece of complexity
and that is that if there's some
follower out there whose log ends before
the point at which the leaders log
starts then unless we invent something
new we need monney install snapshot
unless we invent something new that
follower can never get up-to-date right
because if the followers you know if
there's some follower whose log only is
the first two log entries we no longer
have the log entry three that's required
to send it to that follower in an append
entries RPC to allow its log to catch up
to the leaders now
we could avoid this problem by having
the leader never drop part of its log if
there's any follower out there that
hasn't caught up to the point at which
the leader is thinking about doing a
snapshot because the leader knows
through next index
well actually leader doesn't really know
but the leader could know in principle
how far each follower had gotten and the
leader could say well I'm just never
gonna drop the part of my log before the
end of the follower with the shortest
log and that would be okay they might
actually just be a good idea period the
reason why that's maybe not such a great
idea is that of course if a follower
shut down for a week you know it's not
gonna be acknowledging log entries and
that means that the leader can't reduce
its memory use by snapshotting so the
way the raft designs chosen to go is
that the leader is allowed to throw away
parts of its logs that would be needed
by some follower and so we need some
other scheme that append entries to deal
with the gap between the end of some
followers log in the beginning of the
leaders log and so that solution is the
install snapshot RPC and the deal is
that when a leader we have some follower
whose log is that you know just powered
on its log as short the leaders gonna
send it and append entries and you know
it's gonna be forced the leaders gonna
be forced to backup and at some point
the leader you know failure or fail
dependent recalls will cause the leader
to realize it it's reached the beginning
of the actual log its doors and at that
point instead of sending in append
entries the leader will send its current
snapshot plus current law well send its
current snapshot to the follower and
then presumably immediately follow it
with an append entries that has the
leaders current law
questions
yeah I'm the sad truth this is like this
is adds significant complexity here
Jarrell I'm three partially because of
the kind of cooperation that's required
between raff this is sort of a little
bit of a violation of modularity it
requires a good deal cooperation like
for example when an install snapshot
comes in it's delivered to raft but raft
really requires the application to
absorb the snapshot so they have to talk
to each other more than they otherwise
might yes the question is that this is
the way the snapshot is created
dependent on the application
it's absolutely it so the snapshot
creation function is part of the
application as part of like the key
value server so raffle you know somehow
call up to the application and say geez
you know I really like a snapshot right
now in the application because only the
application understands what it's status
and you know the inverse function by
which an application reconstructs a
state from a snapshot files also totally
application dependent where there's
intertwining because of course every
snapshot has to be labeled with a point
in a log that it corresponds to
talking about rule six and figure
thirteen okay so yeah the question here
is that and you will be faced with this
in lab three that because the RPC system
isn't perfectly reliable and perfectly
sequenced and RBC's can arrive out of
order or not at all or you may send an
RPC and get no response and think it was
lost but actually was delivered and was
the reply that was lost all these things
happen including to send to whatever
install snapshot our pcs and the leaders
almost certainly sending out many our
pcs concurrently you know both append
entries and install snapshots that means
that you can get things like install
snapshot our pcs from deep in the past
almost anything else right and therefore
the the follower has to be careful you
know has to think carefully about an
install snapshot that arrives and the
yeah I think the specific thing you're
asking is that if follower receives that
an install snapshot that appears to be
completely redundant that is the install
snapshot contains information that's
older than the information the follower
already has
what should the follower do and rule six
and figure thirteen says something but I
think equally valid response to that is
that the follower can ignore a snapshot
that clearly is from the past I don't
really understand that rule six okay I
want to move on to sort of somewhat more
conceptual topic for a bit so far we
haven't really tried to nail down
anything about what it meant to be
correct
what I meant for a replicated service
already any other kind of service to be
behaving correctly and the reason why
and you know whatever for most of my
life I managed to get by without
worrying too much about precise
definitions of correctness but the fact
is that you know if you're trying to
optimize something or you're trying to
think through some weird corner case
it's often handy to actually have a more
or less formal way of deciding is that
behavior correct or not correct and so
you know for here what we're talking
about is you know clients are sending in
requests to the to our replicated
service with our PC maybe they'll be
sending who knows well maybe the service
is crash it can be starting and you know
loading snapshots or whatever the client
sends in a request and gets a response
like is that response correct how are we
supposed to how are we supposed to tell
whether response a would be correct or
response B so we need a notion we need a
pretty formal notion of distinguishing
oh that's okay from now that would be a
wrong answer and for this lab the our
notion of correctness is linearize
ability and I mentioned strong
consistency and some of the papers I
mentioned strong consistency and
basically equivalent to linearize
ability linearize ability is a sort of a
formalization of more or less of the
behavior you would expect if there was
just one server and it didn't crash and
it executed the command client requests
one at a time and you know nothing funny
ever happened so it has it has a
definition and the definition I'll write
out the definition then talk about it so
so an execution history is linearizable
linearizable and this is in the notes if
there exists a total order so an
execution history is a sequence of
client requests maybe many requests from
many clients
if there's some total order of the
operations in the history it matches the
real-time order of requests so if one
request
if client sends out a request and gets a
response and then later in time another
client sends out a request and I get a
response those two requests are ordered
because one of them's started after the
other one finished
so it's linearizable history is
linearizable if there exists an order of
the operations in the history that
matches real-time for non concurrent
requests that is for a request to didn't
overlap in time and each read you can
think of it as each read sees the value
from the most immediately preceding
right to the the same piece of data most
recent right in the order all right this
is the definition let me illustrate what
it means by running through an example
so first of all the history is a record
of client operations so this is a
definition that you can apply from
outside this definition doesn't appeal
in any way to what happens inside the
implementation or how the implementation
works it's something that we can if we
see a system operating and we can watch
the messages that come in and out we can
answer the question was that execution
that we observe linearizable so let me
let me write out of history and talk
about why it is or isn't linearizable
all right so here's an example the new
eyes ability talks about operations that
start at one point and end at another
and so this corresponds to the time at
which a client sends a request and then
later receives a reply so let us suppose
that our history says that at at some
particular time this time some client
sent a write request for the data item
named X and asked for it to be set to 1
and then time passed and at the second
vertical bar is when that client got a
reply through send a request at this
point you know time pass who knows
what's happening when the client got a
reply there and then later in time that
client or some other client doesn't
really matter
sends a write request again for item X
and value 2 and gets a response to that
right meanwhile some client sends a read
for X and gets value 2 and sent the
request there and got the response with
value 2 there and there's another
request that we observed it's a part of
the history request was sent to read
value X and it got value 1 back and so
when we have a history like this you
know the question were that you asked
about this history is is this a
linearizable history that is did the
machinery did the service did the system
that produced this history and was that
a linearizable system or did it produce
a linearizable history in this case if
this history is not linear inaudible
then then Lisa we're talking about I
have 3 we know we have a problem there
must be some some bug ok so we need to
analyze this to figure out if it's
linearizable there's linear linearize
ability requires us to produce an order
you know one by one order of the four
operations in that history so we know
we're looking for an order and there's
two constraints on the
order one is if one operation finished
before another started then the one that
finished first has to come first in the
history the other is if some read sees a
particular written value then the read
must come after the write in the order
all right so we want to order so we're
gonna produce an order that has four
entries the two rights and the two leads
I'm gonna draw with arrows that
constraints implied by those two rules
and then our order is gonna have to obey
these constraints so one constraint is
that this write finished before this
write started and therefore one of the
ordering constraints is that this write
must appear in the total order before
this write this read saw the value of
two so in the total order the most
recent right that this read must come
after this right and this write must be
the most recent right so that means that
in the total order we must see the right
of X - 2 and then after it the read of X
it yields - and this this read of X of 1
if we assume that the X didn't already
have the value 1 there there must be in
this relationship and that is the read
must come after the right and this read
also must become for this right and
maybe there's some other restrictions -
anyway we can take these we can take
this set of arrows and flatten it out
into an order and that actually works so
the order that's the total order that
demonstrates that this history is
linearizable is first the right of x - 1
then the read of x yielding 1 then the
right of x - 2 and the read of x that
yields 2
alright so the fact that there is this
order that does obey the ordering
constraints shows that this history is
linearize ability and doesn't you know
if we're worried about the system that
produced this history whether it's a but
that system is linearizable then this
particular example we saw it doesn't
contradict the presumption that the
system is linearizable any questions
about what I just did each read sees you
know read of X the value it sees must be
them value written by the most the most
recent proceeding right in the order so
you know in this case in this case we're
totally ok with this order because this
read the value it saw is indeed the
value written by the most recent write
in this order and this read the value it
sighs I mean in informally it's that
reads can't real should not be yielding
stale data if I write something in Rita
back gosh I should see the value I wrote
and that's like a formalization of the
notion that
oh yes oh yeah yeah all right let me let
me he's right up example that's not
indeed linearizable so example two let's
suppose our history is we had a right of
X value one right back with value two
and so this one we also want to write
out the arrows and so we know what the
constraints are on any total order we
might find the right of X to one because
of time because it finished in real time
before the right x to started and must
come before in any satisfying order we
produce the right of Ecsta two has to
come before the right before the read of
X that yields two so we have this arrow
the read of X had to finished before the
read of X to one started so we have this
arrow and the read of X to one because
it saw value one has to come after the
right of X - 1 and more crucially before
the right of X 2 - right so we can't
have this read of X yielding one if it's
immediately preceded by I'll write out X
- 2 so we also have this arrow like this
and because there's a cycle in these
constraints there's no order that can
obey all these constraints and therefore
this history is not linearizable and so
the system that produced it is
is not a linearizable system you know
would be linearizable the history was
missing any one of these three and I
would break the cycle yes maybe I'm not
sure because suppose or I don't know how
to incorporate very strange things like
supposing somebody red 27 you know it
doesn't really if there's no right of 27
a read of 27 doesn't at least the way
I've written out the rules doesn't sort
of well there may be some sort of anti
dependency that you would construct okay
um I will continue this discussion next
week